your dad's wedding was this weekend all
right on Saturday night on Saturday
night your dad got Billy South Philly
okay tell us about the wedding was it
nice it was a blast my family loves to
party that's what we did really so the
whole I mean I know you like to party
you're legendary people say lordy Lordy
she loves to party yeah no one's ever
said that you posted a picture of your
sister's with your dad at the wedding
and I love this picture what is
happening here first of all your dad
looks very cool you ladies look
beautiful what's happening here so this
is just your typical wedding portrait
that's me and my sisters we were groom's
women oh we stood on my dad's side and
we wore suits and the my middle sister
Natalie was the best man wait so you
guys gave your dad away yeah I've never
heard of that before it must be
happening all the time kind of old
fashioned but that's right I think
that's really cool yeah it was cool I it
was Natalie's idea and it just kind of
spiraled and we were like let's just do
it let's get crazy and and yeah the rest
of my family they they came around like
my grandmother was a little bit like
you're not wearing a dress right I was
like no I'm wearing a suit yeah and she
was like why yeah like it get with it
grandma yeah and she was like I don't
like it go god yeah did she say that or
is that just an old prospector no she
said it exactly like just like that you
a good impression of your grandmother
you